bonjour mademoiselle julie fonction
monsieur qu'elle désirait bas où vous ne
reconnaissez pas j'avoue que votre
visage ne m'est pas inconnu voyons et
1000 et 1100 pagne le factor aux acteurs
et bien j'ai tellement l'habitude de
vous voir en uniforme que je n'arrivais
pas vos pubs dans votre costume il ne
vous déplaît pas au mois ont pas du tout
les élégants ça ça me fait plaisir c'est
gentil bonjour je dis je ne veux surtout
pas déranger bonjour monsieur
excusez moi je mets ces nouveaux acteurs
je me savais pas retenu à l'élégance
vous le trouvez bien mon ensemble
ce terme a expliqué nous ce qui vous
arrive
voilà c'est mon jour de congé alors j'en
profite pour aménager mon nouveau
logement
puis nouveau le chien oui ah ça vous
savez julie il n'est pas bien grand mais
et au milieu des fleurs c'est formidable
a pour sûr quand on est dans l'île aux
enfants rien les plus magnifiques je
vous l'installez touchant oui il faut
que je me dépêche sinon je n'arriverai
pas à faire la moitié du travail
mais facteur mais mais pas question de
vous laisser seuls nous allons tous nous
aider et nous met en face à ces très
gentille mais voilà même dire au port
bonjour quasi tout va bien donc
bonjour monsieur secteur
vous avez un nouvel univers
enfin ce n'est pas un uniforme casimir
c'était mon costume dès dimanche de
congé
le facteur s'installe aujourd'hui dans
une nouvelle maison et nous allons tous
les déchets d'accord armée très bien
d'accord visant à relancer le chantier
mais qu'est ce que tu fais mais nous ne
savons même pas ce qu'il ya à faire
alors c'est toujours pareil chaque fois
qu'il ya quelque chose d'amusant
il faut apprendre à écouter casimir si
tu es d'accord c'est toi qui va
commencer en faisant les courses
enfin moi je veux bien mon jeu j'adore
faire les courses et c'est parfait ça
leur facteur de poids avec vous attendez
françoise schéma liste voilà il me
faudrait un produit pour nettoyer le sol
et un gros pot de peinture verte pour
peindre les murs bon ça se trouve à la
droguerie ou chez le marchand de
couleurs comme je voudrais avec la
pensée ensuite il nous faut quelques
clous et puis un marteau à kkr et
françois g on couvre lit déchiré et bien
du fil et des aiguilles à la mercerie
s'il est un facteur avait vue pour ces
rien si nécessaire de nouvelles à vos
amis course ou franchement j'ai
complètement oublié ça alors c'est la
meilleure on aura tout vu
un facteur qui oublient décrire ses amis
casimir kazemi au lieu de rire ajoute
sur ta liste du papier à lettres et des
enveloppes apprendre à la papeterie
bobos si on peut pas en rigoler un peu
et si nous étions calmes et voeckler
facteurs pour surgeler cendres la maison
bien piqué alors casimir quelques roses
chez la fleuriste d'accord rouag
ailleurs pour voir autre chose acteurs
n'ont donc pour les pour l'instant je le
vois plus rien franchement on va y
croire nous avons pensé à tout ah non
non non moi je pense que si c'est toi
françois qui plantent les clo il serait
prudent lâcheté du mercurochrome et du
sparadrap très bonne idée et si tu
trouves à tout ça à la pharmacie
parfait bon eh bien nous allons y aller
maintenant casimir toi tu vas faire des
courses et du nous rejoint ensuite ce
facteur bonsoir oui à temps s'il te
plait je voudrais te demander un petit
service avec plaisir que je vous
rejoindre deux minutes mais c'était pas
non à tout de suite françois merci à
tous et à tout de suite dans casimir
pourquoi vouloir réparer
oui le bon voilà je je ne sais plus très
bien où acheter toutes ces choses là
j'ai bien peur de tout mélanger et en
secret alors ça m'a signe enfin si tu as
également à la mercerie à la papeterie
il y avait aussi la quincaillerie et les
fleuristes et et la droguerie voilà qui
signa tu veux que j'appelle les enfants
ça c'est une très bonne idée parce que
ils sont formidables il trouvera
toujours tous les enfants venez vite
vous n'ayez besoin
vous allez m'aider un rené elle voilà ce
qui d'accord casimir à des courses à
faire et il le sait pas chez quel
marchand ou dans quel magasin et glace
rendre voulait bien l'aider attendu et
vous si chez vous parfait on doit
désigner d'un couteau je vous explique
un cd course pour le facteur pour sa
maison il faut que j'achète un produit
pour nettoyer le sort chez qui casimir
doit-il se rendre au gabon à la droite
libre c'est pas chez le fleuriste
donnez-nous casimir ensuite des du
papier à lettre papier à lettres draps
pétri très bien à ce qu'un prix étant
déjà meurtri papeterie il me faudra
quelques fleurs aussi quelques fleurs
608 ce sera très joli chez facteurs
influant suite du mercurochrome merkel a
placé ses côtés le maire comme ça c'est
pour françois s'ils se donnent des coups
de marteau sur les doigts il croit que
je suis pas très habile greg ensuite un
gros push de peinture verte
tout le temps qu'ils reversent à la
droguerie c'était le deuxième arrive et
que je note des clous des clous desclaux
à la clé j'espère que chez eux
casini à nos amis cherchent aussi à
trouver les bonnes réponses ensuite que
flash terre du karabagh des sparadraps à
la faire mais je ne sais pas quand on
mange quoi mais oui ça va avec le
mercurochrome la 2 arte pharmacie
séparera du fils et fils mercerie d'ici
là mais c'est mieux sourit bon voilà un
marteau pour aller à yquelon à la
quincaillerie d'accord des enveloppes à
la frapper très bon d'accord bah oui
c'est un blanc c'est comme le papier à
lettres ensuite est la dernière chose ce
sont des aiguilles des aiguilles xp des
aiguilles à la mercerie évidemment
séduit à la mercerie alors hein c'est au
casino
oui ça fait avec le film les aiguilles
c'est tout c'est tout merci les enfants
vont rejoindre vous étiez-vous casimir
maintenant il faut te dépêcher bovine
enfin bon du coin oh là là mais casimir
qui n'a plus l'air très enthousiaste
bonjour mes très chers année à bonjour
monsieur je sais tout mais ne partez pas
vous tombait à point
ah bon julie m'a chargé d'une commission
pour vous ah bon mais des mois sa vie de
casey mais là il faudrait que vous
alliez acheté tous à tout faire moi
c'est à dire que je n'ai pas beaucoup de
temps disponible
enfin c'est pour cette très chère julie
je vais tout de suite à tout à l'heure
mais pas se désarmer
casini mais j'y comprends plus rien tout
à l'heure du thé ravi à l'idée d'aller
d'aller faire les courses pour julie et
maintenant tu lui envoies monsieur du
snob mais alors que s'est-il passé
il s'est passé que j'ai réalisé que
n'ont aucune de ses six buts et on le
trouve des choses à manger
kazim et
[Musique]